[Musique]
les allemands sont arrivés ne sert pas
ce prix directement
naturellement nous étions mis les mains
ou et on nous raconte interrogé on a cru
que vous avez dit larmes
et quand ils ont vu que nous n'avons pas
des gens ils n'ont rien fait maudit
avant avant pis tu as les cinq minutes
mais tout à coup de dons qui était en
charge a vu mon coffre du tenant que
j'étais dans la guerre 14 18
je regarde il qu'est ce que c'est ça
jeudi j'étais deux noms dans ce gala
alors ne savais pas quoi faire voulais
pas le croire mais pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez caché alors ce n'est pas
nécessaire c'est nécessaire il ils ont
pris tous les gens même ceux qui avaient
le coi premier ordre et les les jeux des
autres ça ne fait rien à vous avez le
temps vous avez le temps et le laisser
faire ce que nous voulons j'ai eu le
temps de préparer autre avec nous ce
qu'il fallait mais 1 1 ne voyez pas son
sens au journal as ce temps là on était
occupé avec d'autres questions
naturellement mais après ça nous étions
fossier de de talent et bas où il y
avait une voiture on aura pris en prison
l'un après nous étions séparés mais
après je croise était six ou sept jours
on nous a pris pour le camp des vestes
borg
et là on est ensemble nouveau dans les
femmes étaient séparés du stream de gens
mais le soir on a travaillé on a fait
toutes choses pour que p mais là le soir
on était ensemble et on était avec tes
terres les premiers là elle était assez
d parce que maintenant elles n'étaient
pas forcés de rester dans ce mur il
avait il y avait du soleil il avait
nature et n'avait pas réalisé
ça devra et nous on espérait tous qu'il
n'ya plus des transports pour les
grandes sensations mais après nous étant
là pour quelques temps c'était le
dernier transport qui était cantonné
pour ensuite et on arrive on a ensuite
naturellement là il y avait des gens
avec des bâtons et monsieur ici les
femmes là alors c'était le dernier comme
la famille et là vous les avez perdu
vous les avez plus vu non c'était fini
depuis ça c'était le dernier
et quand vous êtes revenu
comment avez vous su de ce qu'était
devenu votre femme et vos enfants est ce
que vous avez eu des nouvelles ou via ce
qui vous a fallu attendre longtemps un
j'ai eu des nouvelles de ma femme il y
avait une dame qui était avec ma femme
jusqu'au dernier moment les mauvais et
quand nous sommes allés d'auschwitz à
katowice et elle en est
le lundi pour rentrer c'est un mal vu et
m'a raconté les derniers heurts de ma
femme elle m'a dit que les enfants
étaient pris pour une autre quand ce pas
ne savais pas dans le temps et que ma
femme a été très très triste parce que
les enfants ont dû partir et qu'elle
était trop faible
mauvais de négociation mais de mes
enfants je ne savais rien j'avais cru
que le retour n'avait j'avais toujours
espéré jeux viendront jusque il ya deux
mois quand un de mes amis m'a raconté il
ya du dans le jeune fille qui avait qui
ai été avec un et margaux abib elle est
racontée
margot et amusement c'est seulement
après ça quelques jours après que mip
m'a donné le journal thanh qu'elle a
rêvé parce que là vous du donner en ct
ok mais comment l'at elle retrouvait ce
journal vous deviez vous auriez dû
l'emporter normalement
on en a écrit son journal
et un jour il m'a dit papa tu sais
j'écris mon journal et je ne veux pas
qu'on voit c'est écrit ces mots sur dix
dans ma chambre
un tiroir là mais je crains que qu'on
veut être curieux et voir ce que j'écris
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
alors j'ai dit j'ai là ma serviette
je n'ai pas besoin maintenant il ya par
des affaires pour un dicton journal met
tout dedans et le soir tu le mets à côté
de mon lit je te promets que personne de
nous va regarder ce qu'il ya et
naturellement elle savait quand on
promet hauteur sa promesse et c'est ce
qu'elle a fait mais plus tard lors quand
nous étions arrêtés le 1er mai question
des gestapo
c'est monnaies des précieux ou devais
avoir quelque chose
il a pris la monnaie il a vu la
serviette
ils apprenaient vous voyez qu'il ya des
écritures
on a eu bien des spéciales dedans il est
mis sur la terre elle a pris les
précieux et de leur monnaie bt 12 dans
la serviette et c'est tout
non c'était sûr sur la terre tous les
véhicules dans l'ain et plus tard ils
ont pris l'argent
ce camp de l'arbre kaunas était
enveloppée dans des journaux
ils ont pris ça les vieux journaux terre
alors content quand on est allé vous ne
regardez pas on n'avait pas le temps de
me garder
léana n'a jamais parlé même aucun champ
de concession de veste bar où nous avons
n'a pas parlé de son journal après des
allemands en piller tout il y avait
aussi des albums de photos de famille
il y avait des livres hollandais ça ne
l'intéressé pas tout seul sur la terre
parce qu'il croyait que un temps d à moi
il aura encore d'autres choses
alors ces choses là tous et ses petites
choses sont restées là le est tout ce
qu'on avait été pillé et en forte et
alors qu'on à nettoyer la place mii
prévenu en vaut et elle voyait là et
continental elle a pris tous les jours
journal qu'elle a vu et les a regardés
elle n'est pas lui elle voulait
d'étonner ce n'était pas possible la
tonnelle et vous vous avez lu ce journal
pour la première fois vous n'aviez
jamais lui sert tellement je n'ai jamais
voulu en a lu quelques passages
humoriste qu'elle voit des petites
histoires qu'elle a écrit l'histoire du
temps this toutes des choses pareilles
mais jamais quelque chose de ses idées
de ce que les sentiments winamp elle n'a
jamais est ce que vous n'avez pas
découvert votre fille en lisant ce
journal j'ai vu que je ne connaissais
pas on croit être en relation on était
en bonne relation mais je demande
beaucoup de parents ici même est ce que
vous connaissez vos enfants
ça c'est une question très importante
parce que je crois le développement d'un
collage de 13 à 15 ans c'est un âge si
difficile que beaucoup de parents et
beaucoup de jeunes gens ont des
difficultés
le peuple
[Musique]